des roses par milliers attendent d'être
offerte rouges blanches ou encore jaune
plus de 700 espèces différentes sont
cultivés sur cette propriété de 8000
mètres carrés située à une heure de
bordeaux plus de 80 % de nos ventes se
font sur les ford au printemps donc à
mon sens c'est irrattrapable est la
seule manière de rattraper ses ventes
que l'on perd en partie du moins c'est
que les gens se déplacent et viennent
sur notre exploitation
le problème actuellement c'est que les
gens ont peur de se déplacer parce que
ce n'est pas un achat de première
nécessité et ils ont peur de se faire
contrôler par la police
donc on a le droit de vendre mais eux
n'ont pas le droit de venir
non c'est quand même un dilemme pour les
mois de mars et avril la crise sanitaire
a entraîné une baisse de 95 % de son
chiffre d'affaires une première pour les
mares horticulteurs depuis plusieurs
générations
philippe dit avoir déjà perdu 158 euros
et l'après 11 mai ne s'annonce pas très
rose ça va avoir un impact colossal dire
surtout pour les les gens qui greffent
les rosiers pour nous dire là ils sont
en train de préparer la saison 2009 22 2
et donc savent pas ce qu'ils vont faire
ont déjà tout ce qui a été greffée
l'année dernière nous avons d'énormes
difficultés à les vendre puisque bon bah
on n'a pas acheté grand chose puisque
tout est dans notre exploite dans nos
exploitations et donc ils vont
énormément perdre de chiffre d'affaires
sur
2020 2021 et 2022 c'est la grande
incertitude
après dire quand on a des grosses
exploitations il faut il faut arriver à
tenir parce que les les annonces faites
par le gouvernement ne sont pas
forcément en adéquation avec ce que les
horticulteurs reçoivent pour limiter la
casse philippe affirme qu'il lui reste
cinq à six semaines avant que les roses
ne s'abîme
ils ne deviennent impropres à la vente
ce jour là le sourire fleuri dans
l'exploitation avec une cliente venue
faire c'est un challenge extrêmement
profond le rosier beau mais si je me
fais contrôler je leur dirai la vérité
je suis venu chercher des rosiers pour
aider à faire vivre comme on peut aider
aussi à un éleveur de poulets
voilà c'est la même chose pour moi du
producteur aux fleuristes en boutique
toute la filière est impacté par la
crise duo kobe 19
nul ne sait de quoi l'avenir sera fait
mais tous espèrent revoir très vite la
vie en rose